the only clips i saw at the olympics was
that they're playing a lot of anime
music yeah a lot of people are doing
anime stuff yeah yeah so when you come
out in boxing you're allowed to play
your own music yeah yeah yeah and some
of them one of them the demon slayer one
of the japanese guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
i saw there was a greek person who did
that yeah i did like year two in one
piece and one the [ __ ] one uh gold
medal as well what a bad i think he said
a record as well so i'm just like yo one
piece stands founder of one piece stands
like [ __ ] stand up now yeah the i
think one of the volleyball matches with
the japanese team they'll play in the
haikyuu theme
like during like the intervals
and i'm like that's so cool but yeah
like the opening the only cool part
about the opening ceremony was the fact
that that from what i saw because like
admittedly like compared to some of the
other opening ceremonies that i've seen
it was a very artistic one i'd say yeah
[Applause]
you know what that means it was history
it was very bare bones it was bare bones
like the the references i think that
people were looking for were not in the
opening so i think a lot of people are
hoping that it comes out in the ending
ceremony but i think the only cool thing
was that during the time when all of the
countries were coming out because that's
like a like an hour and a half segment
of like all the countries coming yeah
they were playing like just
basically the entire discography of
square enix games
like literally every square enix game
you could think of they were playing the
musical so like they literally opened
with like the dragon quest theme and
like they're playing final fantasy
chrono trigger like [ __ ] near they've
played a [ __ ] near autopsy yeah i i
heard them but
literally the most darkest depressing
mirror
that plays in like a really sad scene in
the game
and it's like malta and it's just like
[ __ ] like
this [ __ ] sad near all of others
it's really weird but like i'm just
thinking like because you know i think
the biggest question everyone had who
watched the opening is like
where's all the nintendo [ __ ] yeah
that's what i was pokemon where's mario
where's all that stuff that they
promised that like it's kind of hard
because normally japan has been quite
patriotic with all of its especially
pokemon
japan is not as sweet what's the word uh
japan has not been scared to embrace
pokemon right national symbol and like
you know considering the fact that at
the end of the last olympics yeah the
mario thing yeah like a prime minister
came out of a pipe dressed as mario
right it could be a thing if nintendo
didn't want to do it or it could have
been a thing of or i think what a lot of
people are waiting for is because they
were like square enix we'll let you take
the opening
but nintendo
is the end i don't know
that's why by the time this has come out
we'll know the answer yeah i guess so
but like that's as of right now that's
what i think all the theories are but
yeah i mean like do you think the
opening was purposefully done the way it
is or is it just because of the world
situation that they couldn't make it
bigger
oh that's what i i think i think it's
the latter did you go back and watch
other opening ceremonies i did yeah i do
i what's the one at the the beijing
olympics like that one was insane
compared to like japanese i mean the
japanese one was good don't get me wrong
yeah but i definitely did feel that i
think the world situation really did
screw it over in a lot of ways yeah
because i was like
i liked the idea that they were going
for but i feel it was like a little
underperformed just like where's the
budget yeah right
it really didn't feel like i just won't
have the [ __ ] queens yeah yeah yeah
i'm like how much did that cost
daniel craig be james bond there's no
way he did that for less than like 50
million exactly he literally hates james
bond
as we've established why would he want
to do that exactly right for queen and
country obviously
so that's that's why i was hoping that
like you know they would have at least
you know some more like notable like big
big people coming out in the opening
right because like that's you know the
way to like open for your country and
like be braggadocios about your country
for years but i feel that like that's
the one time you can actually brag yeah
right and like people are waiting for
you to brag but like i feel like the
references that they did throw in were
like
super [ __ ] subtle and like
kind of offhand or like what was that
guy that was tap dancing i didn't get
that
he was literally okay yeah he was
literally i think it was he's
the greatest tap dancer in japan wait to
explain what was going on i watched him
i remember that so there was this tap so
what they did instead was instead of
bringing out these like notable names
they brought out like
japan's best
blank so like they had like japan's best
tap dancer and he was performing and
they're like they had japan's best like
jazz pianist yeah i do remember this and
i i think i was like why are they
bringing in tap dances in japan yeah
also during a really like traditional
like wood scene yeah that's why i'm like
this
it's like 400 years of difference
between tap dancing and like edo curious
you know what i think japan i don't
think tap dance
i don't think tap dancing in jazz
piano it was just so surreal seeing like
a tap dancer dancing on a stage with
nothing on it to a crowd of zero people
in a stadium that's meant for like
thirty thousand yeah yeah
it's so depressing seeing all the
studios empty yeah i actually read that
uh they so the guy who designed like the
the actual stadium he to make you know
because obviously they couldn't put
people into the stadium so what they did
was he purposely designed the seats and
arranged the colors to make it look like
there were people sitting from a
distance what how could that did
[ __ ] didn't that that was the intent
i think yeah but uh yeah obviously you
know to varying degrees of success i
mean i think a lot of it was unfortunate
because i i think another thing about
the tap dancing is that it's because the
stadium was so big and i don't think the
microphones were sensitive enough i
couldn't [ __ ] hear it it was at that
point it was just like [ __ ] stepping
with attitude that's that's kind of what
it felt like the commentators even in
the i was watching on japanese they were
explaining what was going on more than
they were letting their audio play yeah
so
how good of an opening ceremony is that
if i need i actually need a narrator
telling me what's happening like legit
some of the stuff was so avant-garde
yeah it was crazy but like sixty percent
of the commentators were like doing
[ __ ] like audio commentary yeah they
were telling them
exactly what was going on
this represents blah blah blah and i'm
like just let me watch it shut up just
let me watch it's not very good if i
can't discern what's going on right
exactly yeah i was watching it through
the british commentary and there wasn't
too much commentary because i think they
were just as confused as that
what's going on
it's not a good opening ceremony if you
[ __ ] talk over all of it yeah exactly
i don't go and watch of mice and men and
have someone narrate in my ear what's
why why lenny is doing all this [ __ ] you
know what i mean i i don't need this
[ __ ] let it speak for itself that's it's
oh my god i think i think the speech
afterwards of like the olympic committee
actually went on for longer than the
performances yeah
i zoned out yeah yeah so yeah i don't
know like maybe that was because of a
budget problem maybe because of the
world situation but i mean like i think
a lot more people i think the only good
thing that came out of it was probably
square enix's stocks went
because of like the amount of music they
used at the beginning i want to know how
square enix was basically just got over
to got to like take over the opening
ceremony yeah i've noticed there's so
many other like
japanese yeah but they literally like
you know had the actual spotlight at
that point like i remember as well like
it wasn't just square enix music they
literally played a song from [ __ ]
sonic adventure 2.
are you serious there was yeah one of
the songs that played in the set because
the set piece uh like was leaked on
twitter before the actual like beginning
of that segment and in the list there
was a [ __ ] sonic song rolling around
i think i would
the best opening ceremony of all time
but yeah they literally i don't think it
was song adventure 2 it was one of the
sonic games but they legitimately played
a sonic song and i'm just like i mean
sonic's pretty [ __ ] iconic i mean hey
man like they did it i guess how did
sega get in and then nintendo just
didn't then i don't and i think that's
why like that's where the confusion
arose of like okay so like
obviously more people know when you
think of japan from like a foreigner's
perspective you think pokemon and mario
yeah yeah like you don't think of final
fantasy and sonic would you say song is
more famous than final fantasy
it is right sonic yeah probably probably
you know weird because
he's only had like three good games yeah
he literally just like he's coming on
the bus
yeah he's literally cashing in on the
brand recognition
he is sonic is one of those sonic riders
though okay
i recognize that it's not the best game
sonic riders battle adventure 2 is good
and sonic heroes was weirdly good too
but but isn't it strange though how
sonic hasn't had like the biggest
smash hit games yet he's still like the
one of the most recognizable that's the
thing sonic is purely surviving off of
character design brand recognition like
he's he's just an icon his character
design is poor [ __ ] it's
brilliant it's gonna be all pulling up
that's her
but
it's just the cult following all right
like you know after sonic uh the sonic 3
right like we haven't had a single like
mainly yeah well i mean yeah but i mean
it's kind of a remake of it yeah yeah i
mean that's up for debate i mean it's
all like been 2d sonic's there hasn't
been a good 3d sonic all the 2d sonics
were fantastic
all the 3d sonics except for writers was
you know absolutely trash and yet they
can somehow pump out all these sonic
[ __ ] sonic games and people are still
just like i mean the next one might be
if you don't play mario and sonic at the
olympic games no i haven't i [ __ ]
love oh
i've always wanted to play that game on
the 2008
beijing olympics one you couldn't get a
copy of that in the uk it was like solo
everywhere i'm surprised they didn't do
a re-release for this olympics i think
they did last they did last year
yeah they did last year